[Music]
the gang's all back for neighbors to
sorority rising seth rogen Roseburg and
Zac Efron but this time around Zach is
actually on the other side their side as
they battle us are already gone rogue
our Ashland cousteau was first on the
set and lucky for her well the fact
likes to do his fighting shirtless does
this Zach always working out and looking
in great shape does that just annoy the
crap out of you Zach does that ones
former enemies Zach and Seth now need to
join forces in order to take on the new
neighbors a sorority led by Chloe grace
Moretz they always say oh boys are
scarier than girls when you see what
we're doing right now you realize very
quickly that having a herd of women
chasing Seth Rogen down a tailgate is
much scarier Ashlyn is in costume to be
an extra for the epic tailgate scene in
the movie I just did some night
woodrose burn returned to place s wife
for pregnancy it worked out perfectly
they kind of wrote it in and she was
gonna be pregnant later and then they
just worked out and the secret's out
Selena Gomez gets in the fight
she's super funny she's awesome
yes she's super talented she's tiny
that's stored about five four or five PI
well by the way the new trailer is being
released tomorrow and you can watch it
on our website easy online calm
[Music]